so check out this dramatic life-saving  rescue in China video shows a three year  old boy clinging to the edge of a  sixth-floor apartment balcony on Monday  while he dangled high in the air a group  of Oh thinking people I know they  grabbed a blanket they stretched it out  and seconds later you see there the boy  fell safely into the blanket he was not  hurt police say he was left alone at  home when his grandmother went out for  groceries oh grandma is that Ricky okay  you know I don't know but I don't think  you should have really I'm not a parent  I can write a book saying I'm not a  parent but you don't leave your this  time alone not a toddler teenagers are  trouble about the window but they can  actually do even more damage that's a  really funny